hey guys P here this is going to be my
Game of Thrones season 7 episode to
recap and review if you haven't watched
episode 2 yet you're going to want to
stop watching this video because we're
going to talk about everything that
happened keep in mind if you're new to
my channel I do a scene-by-scene
breakdown first and then get into a
discussion afterwards if you don't want
to watch the scene by scene check the
description I put a timestamp link in
there where you can skip straight to
that discussion
all right so episode 2 opens with a
storm for Daenerys Stormborn some pretty
cool shots of Dragonstone there with the
lightning going and we hear Tyrion say
on a night like this you were brought
into the world or you were born there it
says that he remembers that storm but
pretty quickly
Daenerys redirects things I mean she
says she doesn't feel like Dragonstone
doesn't feel like home I mean she really
doesn't have a home if you think about
it but yeah she's not very happy so
Tyrion tells her that they won't be
there for very long and they look over
the map there for a bit and she mentions
that there aren't many lions Varys then
steps in to say that she only control
Cersei only controls fewer than half of
the Seven Kingdoms he says that the big
families were plying against them at the
crown even before Daenerys came it turns
into this cool exchange between Dany
embarrassed Varys is kind of blowing
smoke up her ass on one level but
telling the truth on another and Dany
just sort of cuts to the chase
she basically lets him know she's not
going to fall for any of that kind of
stuff and she calls him out on his past
weasel REE but then instead of like you
know changing things around or whatever
he just stands behind what he did this
may be a different kind of Varys like a
hint towards Varys you know really being
on board this time not only being out
for himself he says he came from nothing
and his true allegiance is to the people
not a king like he wasn't born in a
powerful family she kind of threatens
him to go back and forth at the end they
end up at an understanding which
basically boils down to if she gets off
Bay
if she gets if she's making the wrong
decisions she wants him to tell her not
to just basically go behind her back and
just pick somebody else and you know he
seems on board with this at the end when
they finish up gray Warren tells her
that there's a red priestess from Shai
who has come to see her they head
straight over to the throne room where
Melisandre is and she speaks to her in
valerian tells her that she was once a
slave and then it's an honor to meet the
breaker of chains Dani says that the red
priest helps to bring the peace to
marine so that means that Melisandre is
definitely welcome there then she asked
her name and right away bear springs up
that she used to serve Stannis and then
it didn't turn out very well for him did
it - which Melisandre concedes but Dan
equips that hey you know what you picked
an auspicious day to arrive at
Dragonstone since we've just decided to
pardon those who served the wrong King
as she gives Varys a little look there
so Melisandre picks back up she talks
about the war for the dawn and how only
the prince that was promised can bring
the dawn Danny says well I'm not a
prince and Musante interrupts and says
you know it's not actually the right
translation it's there's no gender in
that word in Valyrian so the right way
to say it would be the prince or
princess that was promised this is more
to Daenerys is liking obviously a
Melisandre says she does believe that
Dany has a role to play but so does
another and she says that other is Jon
Snow the king in the north
at this point Tyrion jumps in and says
that he likes and trusts Jon Snow and
that he is a great judge of character
after all in Melisandre tells Daenerys
to summon him and let Jon Snow stand
before you have him tell you what he's
seen I find it really odd like I found
it odd in season six when Jon didn't
bring it up himself but when they're
asking you know she never says oh yeah
he came back from the dead I brought him
back from the dead but either way we
move on she agrees and she tells Tyrion
to send a raven north to tell Jon
to his queen and to bend the knee but
isn't a big surprise this is what we'd
expect her to do but at the same time we
can't really expect that John's going to
do that so that is a big point that's
going to be a major obstacle going
forward we go back to Winterfell and the
raven arrives in the very next scene we
see this dot that we saw in the sdcc
trailer where there's their training in
the yard young children even girls and
we see that Sansa Davos and John are
reading the message that's from Tyrion
they're suspicious they pretty much
think it's a trap that is too dangerous
to meet Sansa points out that he T being
Tyrion isn't like the other Lannister's
though when Jon asked and that he's
always been kind to her but that doesn't
mean that they should trust them Davos
mentions the dragon fire would work
against the white and I guess what
happens all together is they agree that
what Tyrion said about thirsty on the
throne is true that is a bad scenario
but at this point they still don't want
him to go and be received by Queen
Daenerys we head over to King's Landing
where Cersei is making her pitch that
the Mad King daughter is no different
than him she paints Daenerys his time
and has those in the worst possible
light and then she says that Alayna
Tyrell who some of those people who are
there are her bannermen is an open
rebellion to the crown randyll Tarly
steps forward and mentions the Dragons
like she's coming with three full-grown
dragons which is what Aegon conquered
Westeros with and asked what's the plan
for that then we get our first Qyburn
sighting and he steps up to say they're
currently working on that after they
sort of break up Jaime approaches the
tarly's as he kind of doesn't pay a lot
of tension to Dickon but then he goes
with Randall and they have a little
man-to-man conversation he puffs them up
a little bit he says you know you're the
only commander to beaten Robert
Baratheon in battle on the field not
even Rhaegar Targaryen could do
I mean obviously Rhaegar failed at doing
that and that's where he died
Tarly makes the point that he's sworn an
oath to house Tyrell which Jaime were
bud saying that you've also sworn an
oath to the crown but you know we see
that he doesn't lightly
switch his allegiance from the Tyrells
he mentions knowing the Queen of thorns
since they were young and he doesn't
look interested at all Jaime does a
little diplomacy he says look I know you
don't like my sister but you basically
have to make a choice you either throw
all-in with the Tyrells or you back the
crown if you back the crown you're going
to get something good in return once
it's all over and then we can see that
Randall kind of perks up a little bit we
don't get a resolution though then we go
see our favorite Tarly or at least my
favorite Tarly Sam and we see that a
Bros is examining Jorah the archmaester
says that he let the greyscale go on too
long that he should have cut his arm off
right away as soon as he was touched we
find out a little bit about greyscale
here he says he won't actually die for
some time like maybe 10 or 20 years he
might live but Jorah says what about and
he says you're mine we find out the mind
goes in a matter of months like maybe
six months hey Bros is pretty
matter-of-fact about things he says look
if you were a commoner I would send you
away to Valyria with the stone men right
now you could live out your life there
but since you're a knight I'll give you
one more day when he says that he looks
over at his sword and Jorah does as well
so he's basically saying look if you
want to kill yourself now and save
yourself this whole madness and going to
live with the stone men for the rest of
your years I'm not going to stop you
basically you can do whatever you want
to do he leaves right away samwell's
kind of behind he asked about his family
and then he finds out he's a Mormon I
actually got a little chill whenever
Jorah says Mormont to Sam and Sam
reacted I'm not going to lie but anyways
Evers called Sam so they can't really
get into anything we cut back to King's
Landing we see that Cersei and Qyburn
are walking down below they're talking
about the dragon skulls
used to adorn the throne room he shows
her balerion skull which is gigantic and
he says powerful but not invincible
he tells Circe that Daenerys dragons
were wounded in the fighting pits in
Mereen and then if they can be wounded
then they can be killed said he unveils
the secret weapon that he's been working
on and has her actually tried out like
he gets her behind it today pulled this
lever and I don't know about you guys I
don't know about anybody else really but
I actually caught some feelings about
this I wasn't an early supporter of the
Dragons but I mean I wasn't an early
supporter at all like I made a video
about this a few months back we know
where I talked about why the dragons are
actually cool because I know people have
problems with the idea when they first
hear the story is about dragons or
whatever you know either way it hit me
here like whenever I saw her fire that
into the bolt into the skull you know we
see we've seen Daenerys dragons hatch
and grow and yeah they're vicious beasts
and everything but I feel pretty
attached to them at this point so a
little bit tough they're back over at
the map room at Dragonstone we pick up
on that conversation that we see all we
saw in the trailer you know I talked
about this already yars telling Danny
like head straight over to King's
Landing if you want to you can basically
take it in the day then we get Tyrion we
realize that you know basically everyone
here is just interested in there like
Yara Alaina Loras and like they're just
they're only worried about their revenge
like they want to get even and we see
that Tyrion is very useful here because
he is level-headed you know he brings up
the idea hey if you attack them with
dragon fire yeah you'll win but you'll
kill tens of thousands of innocent
people when they attack Alera says
whatever this is war and they go back
and forth where he you know says hey you
killed Marcelo you know I mean she was
totally innocent and eventually Danny
squashes it theory is clip about her
being the queen of ashes hits home
because she says I didn't come here for
that
so deteriorate lays out their plan which
is actually quite better plan they're
going to have the city cut off they're
going to use the Tyrells who control the
food that also have a big army and the
Dornish soldiers from the south cut
King's Landing off and then they're
going to send the unsullied over to
Casterly Rock to hit the Lannisters
their instead and everybody eventually
gets on board after that Daenerys has a
one-on-one with Elena where she says
look I know that you're here because you
hate Cersei not because you love me but
basically I promise I'll take care of
things I'll make sure that it's made
right and she says you know I want to
bring the peace Elena does her whole
spiel the peace never last Tyrion is
clever but I've known a lot of clever
men and I outlived them all so on and so
forth and she says to Daenerys you're a
dragon so be a dragon we find out that
that that daggers sharpening scene that
we saw over and over and the trailers
was actually grey worm he's getting
ready to go out Musante comes and you
know we see that he was gonna leave that
upsets her he explains that he was never
he never had fear he never had any fear
he was never the biggest he was never
the strongest but he never was afraid of
anything and now that he knows miss Andi
he fears losing her or not ever seeing
her again
I mean it's implied but that's basically
what it comes down to and then they have
a intimate encounter I guess is the way
you could describe it it's a bit long
but it's touching you know what I mean
it it adds some gravity to those two
characters we're gonna mean we like gray
when we've had we've liked him but I
think this kind of makes it a little bit
more tragic if something happens to him
Masada's goes the same goes from Missoni
except for you know she shouldn't be in
any harm like I said it didn't need to
be as long as it was for me but I think
it was fine I think it's derail the
story too much and it was it was done
well we go back to the Citadel and say
I'm asked a Broce if he can cure Jorah
and he basically finds out that the
method is too dangerous and that's why
it's forbidden Sam goes anyways he
starts the procedure which involves
removing the infected layer of skin and
putting a medicinal sob or something on
you know I mean he's based going to cut
off all the greyscale and then put some
medicine all over
it's important to remember I guess here
that a bro said the reason why was the
method that Sam's using the guy who came
up with it actually died of greyscale so
it's very gross though
you're definitely feeling it for Jorah
because he got some rum that was about
it and he can't scream because nobody
can know that they're in there so Sam's
basically playing him cuz I mean there's
no real nice way to put it we see that
Aria meets up with hot pie a little hot
pie reunion it's a little bit of a
surprise in my Aria video the other day
after the photos came out I didn't
mention hot pie because we never really
had confirmation that the actor was back
I mean he days all indoor scene so we
never had a chance to see him anywhere
so I didn't know for sure they want to
get anybody's hopes up but he is here
it's a good scene it's nice I mean it
you know it calls back everything from
the early part it also establishes that
he's a survivor that he's doing okay we
see that Aria you know she sort of
developed into this older person but you
know also at the same time more able to
take care of things I mean she's always
been able to survive obviously but I
feel like this is here so we can see
just how much she's changed
asked about Brienne he says that yeah I
saw her and he doesn't mention the fact
that it was in a trial by combat
basically or you know one one-on-one
combat with the Hound where afterwards
she left the Hound for dead and that she
basically ran away from Brienne because
she didn't want to be with her but most
importantly and I talked about this in
my Aria video as well that she finds out
Jones King in the north
and as I guess she changes her plan and
she doesn't even like hang out like she
just changes her plans immediately and
leave so I'm excited to see that I mean
we all knew that she was probably going
to go north but I'm glad there's no
drawn-out bit it's good to see that no
matter how much she's changed her heart
was still with her family at the
Winterfell John gets the Raven from Sam
about the dragonglass he brings it to
the Great Hall while he's there he also
tells them about the message from Tyrion
and we see Littlefinger perk up at this
but it's also you know he's kind of like
he didn't really run this by
in Davos and salsa he's just basically
rolling at this point he mentions the
Dragons which we said before or saw
before and the trailers you know
everyone sort of gets upset I mean which
we kind of knew would happen from what
we saw even Lyanna Mormont doesn't have
his back on this one you know she says
you can't go south they need the king of
the north in the north but yeah I mean
he shocked everyone including some so
probably more saunter than anything
because she thought this was resolved
but he says he's going to meet with her
he accepted the invitation they
discussed it a little bit like I just
said and everyone's against good even
Lyanna Mormont but obviously everyone
else because they just got behind this
guy now he's taking off and he makes
this point it's not a terrible argument
I don't know think he want anyone over
but he then puts salsa in charge and
that seems to at least pacify the
situation and then he tells them that
him and Davos are going tomorrow there
leave her for white Harbor and that's it
we see him at Med statue we find out
that Littlefinger is the one who
delivered the bones which was kind of a
mystery they did it out of respect for
Catelyn we see where the the choke scene
came from we'd seen this in the trailers
basically Littlefinger tries to get on
his good side he tries to say hey you
know I'm a good guy I like you I want
you to succeed more than anything and I
loved your mother and I love your sister
this is what sets him off he basically
chokes him threatens him and then him
and Davos leave little finger looks but
hurt of course we cut to the big reveal
that everyone was waiting for and that
was my Miriah and her pack arriving it
was actually scary at first there was
all the different wolves descended and
they circled up and it was pretty wild
looking and then we see that night
mariya and you know I mentioned this in
my trailer breakdown that I think that
little wolf was nightmare
and man I was right nightmare he is huge
aria recognizes her though and she
recognizes Aria after a minute and she
says she's going home and why don't you
come with me in it nightmare Ian's not
down she doesn't want to it's
heart-wrenching at the time Aria says
it's not you and you know on first here
you think she's sort of like being
delusional or whatever you know she's
saying oh well this is some other dire
wolf but that's not what she's saying
she's saying it's not you in that you're
not a house dog basically I mean you've
been out here you survived you build up
this super PAC and you know this is who
you are now obviously like everyone I'm
hoping that this won't be the last time
we have a/c Nymeria although it very may
well be maybe we'll hear word or
something I'm not happy about it but I
get it I guess you know at least they
did it in a way that makes sense and in
a way that there's resolution for aria I
guess sort of knew it was going to
happen this way but it's still harsh
anyways we go on the ship we see where
the kiss came from that we kept seeing
over and over again laura is making a
move on
yara and kind of messing with Theon at
the same time and then they come under
attack it's a full-scale battle I mean
it's great visually there's a lot going
on it's really put together well your
hunt makes a crazy entrance like he
comes down on one of those things that I
can't think of the name of but you know
he basically lowers himself onto the
deck of the ship
crushes someone in the process starts
killing instantly Theon and yara spring
into action they start fighting the sand
snakes get the short end of the stick at
the end of the day yara had says taim
downstairs to protect lara the other to
try to take on your--on and he takes
both of them out in pretty brutal
fashion there are pretty good scenes but
yeah there's only one sand snake now and
her
and Ellora are captured Yara ends up
captured and your own kind of called
eonni wants to kill Theon so he's
holding yara and he calls him out and
there's all kind of stuff going on and
he basically wreaks out like he reverts
back to his passive self that he was
under Ramsay he jumps overboard and then
we see him looking on at the fleet
burning we see that nothing's quite
laughs we know that Iran has collected
his prize his present for Cersei the
woman and one of her daughters that
killed Circe's daughter which is pretty
good if you think about it plus he has
Yara so at that point the episode ends
so if you skip the scene by theme
welcome to the video a lot of stuff
happened
I enjoyed the episode but I'm a freak
and you know I was talking to some of my
friends who during the week to watch the
show who liked the show who were really
excited about it coming back but they
were a little underwhelmed with the
first episode and I was trying to
explain you know you well they had to
set the table they had to get the pieces
in place and you know my thought was in
what I told them was is it'll pick up
the trust me and like 2/3 of the way
through this episode I was like oh man I
mean they might lose some people after
all this and not the diehards obviously
but some of the just show only kind of
watchers who don't care as much about
some of these internal things that we
really enjoy seeing getting sorted out
or whatever but then they came pretty
hardcore at the end with the battle at
sea and that I think will was I mean it
was impressive let's be honest I think I
will bring everyone back to the
forefront and now that we only have five
episodes left I mean that we know from
the trailers a lot of stuff that's going
to happen and it's going to be pretty
high octane from here on how the major
points were Varys I mean is Varys really
that trustable all of a sudden and one
of the things that I thought about after
the fact I mean I know that Valatie had
to happen and all but does Varys have no
little birds anymore or whatever like he
knows everything usually
he knew he knew nothing about your on
being a threat out there at the sea
so yeah Varys is a little suspect right
now we'll see how that develops I don't
think he's against Daenerys in any way I
just thought they painted him in a
really like likeable way in this episode
that isn't that consistent with what
we've seen before the Aria stuff was big
it was definitely cool to see the hot
pie cameo I guess you would call it she
needs to get that information that John
was up north I was very excited that she
didn't think twice about going there of
course we know he's leaving but whatever
you know I mean it's good to see that
she's dropped that whole idea of going
to King's Landing to try to kill Cersei
I hadn't thought about the fact that she
might think that the Bolton still had
control so yeah that's all really good
the knight Marius stuff was kind of a
bummer I mean it was a great reunion but
I'm sure most of us wanted to see
Nymeria at her side after that and it
doesn't look like it's in the cards I
was thinking too you know John just left
the noir or you know he just left
Winterfell he's going south we know he's
going beyond the wall after that from
the trailer so we didn't see ghosts at
all so I hope we see him at least at
some point in this season yeah the John
stuff was pretty Telegraph's we knew he
was going to end up heading down there
there was such a heavy influence of
dragonglass in the first episode and you
know as soon as we found out that Sam
was going to be sending him a letter we
knew that that you know itself would
probably send them south but obviously
the Dragons Davos is little mention of
the dragons and their flame versus the
white you know I never bought it for a
second that he was going to think about
letting that go you know you knew he was
going to go he just had to have the
right moment to tell everyone he was
going the songs in Littlefinger table is
set now Littlefinger is going to move
quickly while he has the chance I still
think Santa's going to do the right
thing but we'll see how that duct how
that drama kind of unfold the Olenna
bait center back to Highgarden which
we've seen a lot of hints about a battle
that's going to go down so
we're near there in a field so she's
moving in the right direction Searcy it
has she improved her position there's
nothing else you have to say that she
improved her position by her little
meeting with Iran Iran proved his worth
as a captain I mean he just tore Yara as
Dione apart he claimed his gift
sentenced Aeon overboard in a fashion
that I don't think many of us expected I
mean he didn't even try to fight he just
jumped so that's a big development it's
not going to go over look good with his
men of course and where does he go now
you know I mean he he's basically a
coward he's been proven a coward
Melisandre is a very nice addition to
the season we weren't exactly sure how
involved she would be I mean she had a
child right before they filmed but it
looks like she has probably filmed quite
a few scenes
indoors it's a little surprising that
Daenerys just basically was like okay
I'm down with this person but not really
if you think about the amount of time we
have left and everything else I mean we
don't have a lot of time for things to
develop like relationships to develop
what we didn't see was we did not see
any hound or Brotherhood without banners
we didn't see any brand or any stuff at
the wall I'm kind of glad that we didn't
get any hound this time because I've
been looking at some stuff about him and
I wanted to put out a video so yeah I
can do that too sweet since he didn't
show up but I also mentioned in the
trailer breakdown that I put out right
before this you know we don't see any
hound or Brandon that either I do expect
that we'll see something from them I
mean they're not just going to be gone
for the rest of the season so you might
find out that that's all the brand that
we have at the wall like he basically
just passed through and that he'll be
trout he's been traveling the hounds
been traveling and the next time we see
them they're going to end up where they
are so yeah I think it was solid overall
the trailer was definitely excited to
make sure you check out my trailer
breakdown big things are going to happen
in Episode three for sure please like
this video if you enjoyed it make sure
to chime in in the comments let's get a
discussion going I would do a Q&A as
well
all of you asked questions and there are
some things that we need to look at
please subscribe to my channel because
I'm doing a full schedule of Game of
Thrones all throughout the season just
like I did last year whenever they were
doing the filming follow me on Twitter
and my other social media accounts
because that's the easiest way to
interact with me but definitely leave
comments as well alright that's it
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon